we begin with this president Trump is
showing us what his re-election campaign
will look like in his first rally since
the completion of the Mullah report the
president spoke for nearly an hour and a
half in Grand Rapids Michigan last night
he claimed victory for the investigation
that found no grounds to charge him with
collusion after three years of lies and
smears and slander the Russia hoax is
finally dead the collusion delusion is
over the president made fresh attacks on
Obamacare and his opponents as his
supporters cheered him on major Garrett
is at the White House major good morning
good morning for the time that the
Muller investigation began President
Trump told rally crowds he never
conspired or colluded with Russians and
boy did those crowds believe it last
night in Michigan he acted as if the
Attorney General summary of that
underlying report was essentially his
good housekeeping seal of proof and he
said as a result his Democratic critics
are politically dead and his re-election
will be a breeze the single greatest
political hoax in the history of our
country and guess what
we won it's a beautiful thing for a
president who loves to tell the nation
and the world he's always right
president Trump relished his first
campaign rally after the completion of
the Russia investigation it was a
profane victory lap the Democrats have
to now decide whether they will continue
defrauding the public with ridiculous
book
the president who as a candidate led
chants of Locker up against Hillary
Clinton missed the irony of this post
mulher observation in this country we
cannot criminalize political differences
without having seen the mullah report
mr. Trump acted as if he had nothing to
fear even though the report runs more
than 300 pages Democrats he said had
overplayed their hands and may not
recover and this group of major losers
they're on artificial respirators right
now they're getting mouth-to-mouth
resuscitation
a recent CBS News poll shows 77% of
Americans want the special counsel
report released know Thank You mr.
Attorney General
we do not need your interpretation House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi dismissed Attorney
General William bars for page summary of
Muller's report as condescending show us
the report and we can draw our own
conclusions and Michigan Muller wasn't
the only topic on the president's mind
we have a chance of killing Obamacare we
almost said it
despite Republican misgivings on timing
and tactics he plowed ahead on one of
his biggest legislative failures the
Republican Party will become the party
of great health care it's good it's
important the president called
re-election one big cakewalk when I
campaign it's going to be so much easier
the second time and received
encouragement from the crowd
the Attorney General's still in the
process of reviewing and in some cases
redacting the Mulla report House
Democratic staff tells CBS News one of
the obstacles as expected what to do
with grand jury testimony and evidence
those democratic staffers suggest either
a court order or a subpoena might be
required to bring that into full public
view
Tony major thank you